hey youtubers is Charlie so yesterday in
my core video I asked you all to submit
questions so I picked 10 of them to
answer in this video with one bonus
question
whenever episodes start I'll also be
doing regular Q&A is like the day after
I typically do review videos it's just
an easy way to follow up on things that
everyone had big big questions about
that didn't necessarily get answered the
first time we see an episode with that
in mind here are a few clarifications
from the trailer video so I'm not gonna
go crazy with spoilers from all those
leaked episodes but if you do want to
talk about spoilers just use the spoiler
tag whenever you're commenting this is a
really young Lin beifong in Republic
City we don't know how old she is
exactly only that it's her in her early
years on the police force this airbender
is one of the new main characters
she's from that metalbending city but i
won't say more than that just because
she's kind of important and it's a
little bit spoilery this person is lin
beifong's half-sister we still don't
know who either their fathers were but
we could talk more about it in a future
bonus video it's pretty exciting because
it means that Toph either had two
marriages or if she was just in
relationships with two people that did
not end up in marriages this isn't Ba
Sing se it's actually the misty Palms
Oasis all the other scenes in the
trailer in the desert are probably tied
to this location Ba Sing se is also in
the trailer but it's not this place you
also see it in that scene where Asami is
helping Korra escape on Naga also
there's some news on the premiere date a
lot of people are theorizing that
because the second edition of the rift
comic is coming out July 16th that Nick
will just choose to bump up their
release date to right around then it's
not confirmed so we'll just have to wait
and see in Comic Con is the week after
that comes out so they might wait till
after Comic Con so time to answer some
questions
I don't consider any of these answers to
be super spoilery but consider yourself
warned if you don't want to know
anything about book 3 so here we go
question number 1 chris'll asks is Toph
still alive missing or dead so yeah this
is actually one of the biggest core
questions that's still unanswered
nothing in the leaks or anything we've
heard has said that she is alive or dead
definitively the best info we have is
that at one point she pulled a Zuko and
just became a nomad traveling across the
world and hasn't been heard from or seen
ever since because that's what the
producer said about Zuko at the
beginning of book 1 I think we'll
eventually see top because we eventually
saw Zuko because we see young Lin
beifong and flashbacks we
lisi a middle-aged top like we saw in
book 1 flashbacks I'm actually kind of
wondering now if Lin beifong was on the
police force whenever that yacon stuff
was happening in all those flashbacks
question number two Alice asks how many
episodes are there going to be this
season so they're going to be 13
episodes just like book - whenever
Nickelodeon ordered more episodes of
Korra way way back it brought the total
number to 52 that includes everything
from book 1 book 2 book 3 and book 4 so
obviously that implies that book 4 is
going to be 13 episodes - but we'll have
to wait for confirmation on that nick
has been dead quiet about Korra news so
it's unlikely that they're going to
order more episodes after book 4 is over
if anything with avatar or any future
series happens it's probably going to be
another spin-off series in a couple
years or like an avatar TV movie
question number three Baird asks why are
there so many airbenders all of a sudden
so there are actually a couple theories
in a couple possible answers for this
first there are the repercussions from
last season relating to harmonic
convergence like bringing more balance
to both the spirit realm in the physical
realm makes it easier for people to tap
into their own spiritual energy so this
other answer is a little bit more
plausible and I'm going to call it sky
bison logic last season we saw a herd of
sky bison being bred in seclusion it's
possible that a group of airbenders
could have just been living in seclusion
and everyone just didn't know about them
until book 3 until right now
I have heard a few things from those
leaked episodes that confirm some of
this but they don't provide a lot of
context so the best answers is that
people are in better spiritual alignment
right now and there was a hidden group
somewhere in the world question number 4
action vids asks who is lin beifong's
father
so still nothing about this nothing in
the spoiled leaked episodes has revealed
who lin beifong's father is it seems
like most of Lin's story will focus on
her relationship with her surviving
family members I'm really curious to see
if they reveal who her sisters father
was but not her own father the only
reason I think they choose to do that
would be if Lin's father became a bigger
part of the plot in book 4 like he was a
really important person and they didn't
want to reveal that information too soon
I'm not gonna totally flip out if they
don't tell us it would be disappointing
but I think it'll be a little bit easier
to guess who her father was after we
learned more about her other family
members question
number five Rose asks will Zuko be
helping team Cora or just the White
Lotus so I'm choosing to think of those
plots is the same thing like the White
Lotus is going to be a different plot
from the earth Kingdom plot but
eventually you know both plots do have
to come together by the end of the
season so even if Zuko is off doing his
own thing in the first couple of
episodes eventually he will be working
with Korra
after all the Zuko dragon riding clips I
started to get a lot of Avatar Roku
flashbacks to the original series so I
definitely think he'll give core some
advice at least at some point I'm really
hoping he teaches her how to bend blue
fire that would be amazing question
number six count swag ela says I hope we
get to see Bolin evolve from just being
comic relief so based on all the
information I've seen I think you're
gonna be pleasantly surprised with what
they did with Bolin's character this
season he's always been a comedian and
he's always can it continue to be a
comedian but but I think because we're
spending a lot of time in the earth
Kingdom he'll get a much deeper
character arc it wasn't revealed in any
of those leaked episodes but I'm really
hoping that Bolin learns to metalbend
maka learned to lightning Bend from the
triple triad so it only makes sense that
Bolin would learn his sub bending style
at some point question number 7 Milan
Francis asks could you explain what the
political structure is with the
president and the Fire Nation earth
Kingdom air nomads in the Water Tribe so
think of it is like Game of Thrones in
the Seven Kingdoms in Westeros the
Andals invaded and formed the Seven
Kingdoms there were seven different
kings eventually Aegon Targaryen
conquered Westeros and became the one
king and all the other kings just became
Lords so now think about the Fire Nation
the leader of the Fire Nation is called
the Fire Lord
but before Avatar Aang formed the
Republic of Republic City the Fire Lord
was more like a king so now the leaders
of all those various territories are
just more like Lords and in case anyone
wasn't sure Zuko has passed the title of
Fire Lord on to his daughter she's the
mother of general Iroh that we saw
during season one so even though the
political structure has changed a little
bit the leadership is still hereditary I
think they do have a democratic election
process in the Water Tribe and the air
nomads seem like they don't really have
a set political structure question
number 8 as your Rock's asks is there
any connection between combustion girl
and Azula because they look very similar
I'm not totally convinced that is ULA's
going to be in any episodes it's like
the Sokka
in books 1 & 2 we got Katara but she
never said whether he was alive or dead
she barely referenced him at all so
don't be surprised if Zuko does the same
thing he just doesn't talk about his
sister a lot I do expect them to
reference her at some point
you know even though we never saw Sokka
we did see that statue of him I am
pretty sure we're not gonna find any
statues for Azula though unless they're
like warning signs question number 9
Jack asks is Korra still cut off from
her past lives
yes she's definitely cut off and I've
actually heard some rumors that that's
going to prevent her from entering the
Avatar State supposedly during the
leaked episodes core does not enter the
Avatar State
even during situations when she would
normally be entering the Avatar State
for instance look at this giant sand
shark in the trailer don't you think
that Korra would be in the Avatar state
if this were happening it seems like one
of the big running stories in book 3 is
going to be coral earning to either
reconnect with their past lives or
re-enter the Avatar state like it's
going to be something that's going to
take all of book 3 the producers did an
interview with The Wall Street Journal
after book two finished where they
pretty much implied cores past lives
would not be coming back but they didn't
say flat-out that that was what was
happening she did learn to energy Bend
at the end of book two so I'm hoping
that that's going to be a workaround to
the problem there was this crazy rumor I
saw that said that avatar aang at some
point used energy bending to create a
new Airbender like he gave bending to
someone who was not a bender using
energy bending that's something we've
only seen the Lion Turtles do but it's
possible that an avatar could replicate
that power
it's totally unconcerned in just a rumor
though question number 10 berrak asks
why did they show so many fights in the
trailer if the producers said the chorus
biggest battles would have nothing to do
with her bending so that's actually a
really good question the best answer I
can give you is that Mike and Bryan had
nothing to do with making that trailer
Nickelodeon probably did it as a result
of that fake trailer that was going
around just for clarification whenever
those episodes leaked of fan cut a
trailer made a fan version of the
trailer with a bunch of spoilery stuff
in it supposedly Nickelodeon was more
mad about that fan trailer than they
were about the mistake that led to mundo
Nick posting those episodes early
whenever Mike and Bryan were talking
about cores development her character
development in book three they were just
saying that it wasn't going to be like
another bending contest
like that wasn't going to be the
ultimate battle just seeing who was a
better vendor the other possible reason
for having all those fight scenes in the
trailer is that the person who cut the
trailer was just a random person at the
studio who had no idea what the
narrative of book three was supposed to
be so they just saw a bunch of action
scenes and thought that fans would get
really excited so you end up with a fun
looking trailer but one that ultimately
tells a different story than from what
Mike and Brian are telling in the
episodes it's something that happens
with movie trailers all the time you
just have like the biggest moments from
movies so you get a story that's not
necessarily what the actual story of the
movie is and one last bonus question
Andy asks what is the sub bending
element to air so supposedly it's astral
projection and it's something that
Jinora is doing in the trailer if you
see her right here in this scene she's
not in the spirit world so she's not
necessarily in spirit form I'd say the
best explanation is that she's
projecting herself through space-time so
that she can just pass through walls and
barriers but she's not necessarily in
spirit form like she would be in the
spirit world Jinora is one of the most
spiritual people on the show even more
spiritual than Korra so it totally makes
sense that she would be the one to
figure out this new bending style
whenever I started thinking about it
more I actually thought that she might
have been using the sub bending style
during the book 2 finale last year we
were supposed to see a new sub bending
style but when no one said anything
about it I got a little confused so I'm
guessing that they'll clarify this
astral projection in the first couple of
episodes so thank you so much for so
many questions these are always a ton of
fun to do book 3 is going to be awesome
so I am gonna have so much fun making
Korra bonus videos be sure to subscribe
to get everything
my next bonus video will probably be
about who lin beifong's father might be
so also let me know if you want me to
keep doing weekly Korra Q&A and I'll
just keep posting them right now click
here for my breakdown of the Korra book
3 trailer and click here to learn all
about Legend of Zelda on Wii U that they
showed off at e3 it's going to be really
awesome thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
bye